nein es gibt eine frage meine damen und
herren wir stellten gerade ganz youtube
deutschland ich will mich nicht zu weit
aus dem fenster lehnen aber ich kann
sogar sagen das ist nicht nur youtube
deutschland betrifft sondern die
komplette menschliche geschichte bzw
das komplette universum es geht hier
nicht um solchen dummen fragen die
jahreswende heilmittel gegen
irgendwelche tödlichen krankheiten oder
sonstiges nein freunde geht heute darum
welche youtube passt zu mir
zwei personen gefällt das ja-wort heute
hier versammelt meine damen und herren
auf der website hefte dich und zwar
machen wir heute dieses quitte diesem
küster wirst du welche youtuber freundin
du hast und das wirklich eine sache das
habe ich mich schon mein leben lang
gefragt wird hier wirklich nicht um
irgendwas unwichtige sie die gesundheit
oder sie das universum oder die
entstehung der humanen bestätigte mit
youtube freunden die man haben könnte
aber nicht hat
hey lasst doch mal leichter erste frage
welche haarfarbe sollte eine freundin
haben mir egal bund oder braun bzw blond
ich würde an der stelle auf jeden fall
sagen bund welches teil hast du
letztlich cool elegant kann ich
vielleicht auch alle drei sachen
ankreuzen eigentlich gar nichts davon
ich weiß wirklich nicht was ich bin teil
habe also ich meine ich habe gerade
begonnen
orange t shirt an und altrosa habe ich
nicht ich habe keine hose an ich würde
eher sagen komm bisschen letzte frage
wie groß soll deine freunde seien gleich
groß das wäre schwierig weil ich relativ
groß bin gleich groß größer wie degas
ich habe noch nie ein einziges setze
dich kurs gesehen bei dem keine
kompletten grammatikfehler drin waren
deutschunterricht mit luca
eine ewigkeit bitte hallo und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen deutschstunde
mit luca heute handelt es sich um die
beiden wörter alt und wie und wann diese
wörter oft gleich genutzt von den leuten
etwas steht allerdings eine wesentlicher
unterschied bei diesen beiden wörtern
obwohl sie beide nur drei buchstaben
lang wird das wort benutzt man wenn
dinge verschieden sind also
beispielsweise ich bin schneller alt
jemand ich bin cooler als meine
komplette community und die benutzer
etwas gleicht also wenn ich gleich bild
da gehe ich bin gleich coolem eine
community obwohl jeder wusste dass er
gelogen wäre ich cool er war auch
gelogen hier wird allerdings gesagt
größer wie ich und hier müsste
eigentlich als stehen
das skript bekommen von mir auf jeden
fall meine lieben - ich würde sagen ich
leider wenig weil ich schon relativ groß
beschreiben dass keine freunde keine
ahnung habe ich freunde freunde alles
klar danke dir
die würden mich meine freunde
beschreiben er keine ahnung cool
gechillt lust nicht gejammert wird ich
würde sagen dass ich jetzt nicht so der
schule bin aber auch nicht der gezielte
aber auch nicht der lustige
was bin ich eigentlich dass ich mich
nämlich abstoßen ich würde tatsächlich
sagen dass ich eher so der getöten
bestimmen soll deine freunde will
warum ist das in irgendeiner form
relevant für das ergebnis viele leute
sagen ja wow ich möchte über die mit
einem model hamm oder mit irgendjemandem
der übel kraft bekannt ist nie
ich möchte eigentlich jemand der
komplett deswegen würde ich sagen mir
egal einfach wie viele freunde hast du
viel geht so wenig gibt es da irgendwo 0
ich würde sagen dass ich geh zur aber
ich habe jetzt nicht ultra viele freunde
aber weniger die wache es sehr viele
leute ja keine ahnung wird ein selbst
befreundet sein wollen also gerade in
meiner position hat ein bisschen
bekannter youtuber merkt relativ häufig
dass viele leute an kommen und zu sagen
man merkte dass es keine freunde sind
sondern halt nur irgendwelche die eine
ahnung ob bekanntheit außen oder
irgendwas und das jetzt mal wirklich
real talk zu der sache freunde
es geht wirklich nicht darum das hat mir
wirklich erst für die zeit gefehlt ich
mit dem studium angefangen habe es geht
nicht darum dass man möglichst viele
freunde hat oder haben möglichst
bekannte freunde oder wichtig wo überall
wegen kennen und keine ahnung was geht
darum dass man die richtigen freunde hat
und ich habe halt gar keine freunde
warum machst du den test weil ich heute
eigentlich als video ein karaoke wie die
auf einer karaoke-bar stadt machen
wollte
allerdings aufgefallen dass diese
website gar nicht mehr in deutschland
gibt das man da gar nicht mehr drauf
gehen kann und deswegen muss ich jetzt
ein blödes youtuber freundinnen kurz
machen die möglichkeit ihr steht warum
machst du den text weil es spaß macht
ich war neugierig und mir langweilig
also ich würde tatsächlich sagen
falls spaß macht werk komplett gelogen
wie alt soll seine freundin seien älter
als ich möchte ich eher ungern bringen
sagt jünger als ich angst du gerne
das verwächst sich immer wieder ich
würde sagen dass ich eher nicht so oft
krank wird so gern wie hat dir das herz
gefallen cool gut ganz okay warum kommt
bei jedem scheiß letztlich könne die
frage ob einem nest gefallen hat wir
kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf auswertung
nein nein da bin ich die wahrheit von
dieser website erst mal richtig gut auf
jeden fall zu 40 prozent sind sie zu 60
prozent alles klar wahrscheinlich bin
ich zu 40 prozent 60 prozent zu 60
prozent passt zu dir habe ich wirklich
überhaupt nicht gegenwärtig youtube
nutzen konnten
musiktechnisch komplett begabt also als
die website mir gerade gesagt hat das
baby beauty palace tatsächlich meine
youtube freundin sein sollte habe ich
bin wirklich so gedacht werden kann ich
mich normalerweise eher weniger zu 30
prozent passt zu dir aber auch ex leiter
sie hergestellt und hat meistens immer
gut sie hat meistens immer gut aber nein
freunde ich bin keine youtuber der jetzt
hat video hier gegen die beenden würde
nein ich habe mir gedacht damit das
video einfach ein bisschen länger ist
damit ich ein paar mit roll anzeigen
schalten kann und dementsprechend mehr
geld verdienen wir bitten die pizza
kaufen kann da habe ich mir natürlich
einfach gedacht mach ich doch einfach
noch ein zweites quellen dieser youtuber
fehlt dir in der box und leute bleibt
bitte auf jeden fall bis zum ende dran
weil am ende wird ihr mein neues auto
ja
ich habe jetzt ein austro also bleibt
bis zum ende dran wir fangen jetzt meine
dem quartier und zwar welche
youtube-videos schaust du gern craig auf
youtube auch so verrückte bullen scheiße
es wird also auch gern crafter blog
parodien oder beauty ich würde wirklich
dann irgendwie quält die bullshit oder
blogs und parodien also ich jetzt
einfach mal auf block wie findet
zuhälter sind egal ignorieren komisch
und nervig wird einfach mal sagen sind
egal er leute
habt immer wieder bock darauf dass ich
auch väter aussagen reagiere ich hatte
vor einiger zeit eine serie wo ich auf
händlerkommentare reagiert habe und habe
davon mehrere teile gemacht und jeder
teil hat irgendwie beständige aufrufe
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht wenn ihr
wollt dass ich nochmal auf hater
kommentare reagiere dann jetzt hater
kommentare in die kommentare schreiben
also schreibt jetzt ein kommentar wo ihr
mich komplett auseinander da kommt die
tage in video wo ich darauf reagiere
also schreibt kommentar und las bleibt
da wenn ich das machen soll da würde ich
tatsächlich fragen ein lied julien
benneteau world pictures gewichtig
schock nein das nicht wirklich
schokolade oder schokolade hier schon
relativ wichtig im leben ich würde
tatsächlich sagen auf youtube mit humor
am wichtigsten
auf was dachtest du in den videos gute
qualität
wahrscheinlich shawky einfach nur show
oder ich abonniert zb kanäle immer nur
danach was für sotschi sind
ich bin übrigens ultraschall
wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern was
hast du dir kritikaster shop
welche musik hörst du trendige chillige
musik verrückte musik ich eigentlich nur
die musik die kontraste auf soundcloud
hochlädt dort hat er nämlich letztens
wieder ein neues mixtape hochgeladen
finde den song dingen also eigentlich so
ibm
lucia house remix ist es ab so bisschen
elektronische aber da will ich hier halt
eher vagen trendige musik kleidung
stylus mode wurde ich zum beispiel
gerade hat nicht mal eine hose an da
fliegt der youtuber rudi breakchance
hey leute schreibt auch allemal schoggi
in die kommentare ich hab's ja bisher zu
selten gelesenen diesem kurs der ein
resultat jana wie macht parodien blogs
und redet viel über ernstere themen
dafür ist genau deine 4 kanal hat jana
[Musik]
nichts gegen dich jana aber das ist
jetzt nicht so mein content also ich
weiß wie diese website darauf kommt aber
in meinen augen ist hier halt irgendwie
so ja du dir ein bisschen session ein
bisschen fleisch und ja also das genau
das was ich wirklich anschauen
dort wartet die auch wieder meine damen
und herren wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne mal mike da schreibt mehr hater
aussagen ist gegen mich in die
kommentare
dann kommt die tage im video wie ich
sage tage normalerweise würde ich jetzt
sagen findet ihr bei die eigenen da
können die abonnieren oder klickt auf
die glocke wenn ich schon abonnent
vertiefter blabla aber nein freunde ich
habe mich nicht lumpen lassen ich habe
mir ein neues auto erstellen lassen
ich habe selbst erstellt und das sieht
man auch also das war jetzt von video
und jetzt pro video oder konntet ihr vom
video hier können jetzt in einen kanal
abonnieren oder jungen meinen steckten
ihr findet ihr für andere video einen
bentley auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen
die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]